here's a peek at what guests have to say
after the show okay we're back on the
internet bill kristol do you think we
should invade North Korea isn't it a
bigger threat than Iran I think we
shouldn't I think it's awful the North
Korean regime it's got millions of
deaths it's responsible for millions of
deaths it's got nuclear weapons it's
been a failure of US policy to allow it
to get to the situation it's in but I
have no easy answer now you say you
don't think we should invade no but I
don't think we should be cavalier about
it and just say oh how ludicrous that
idea would be to try to destabilize the
regime and free the people of North
Korea it's a horror but how could we do
like I know but how do you do that short
of invading you do have tried every that
we know well in fact we could do what
we've done a fair amount or we could do
more I think endure what more could we
do he could radio we could radio we
could help South Korea radio you script
this Radio Free Asia and those sorts of
things the kinds of things that I don't
undermine the Soviet Union do you think
of North Korean regime is gonna be in
power forever I don't but I don't I
don't think that'll be help dissidents
could be help the South Koreans pretty
help restaurant the Chinese North Korean
I think them food aid the reality is you
have three ways to do things you could
do military you can do economic
sanctions which only has limited work
you have moral authority which we don't
have that much anymore
that's it and if you don't you know
we've tried the economic route as hard
as we can go at it they don't care
because the regime still gets their food
they don't care if the people starve so
the truth is if we're gonna be honest
with ourselves if we're not going to
invade then we don't care that much I
don't agree with that what do good what
do we do
I think invading is out it is out I
think you get more tension between North
Korea and the Chinese than you ever had
before you saw what the he executed the
the high leadership and all the family
and friends and and and telephone
friends of the rival leader in North
Korea and that was China's the uncle you
mean yeah the uncle and all of us
friends family attacked by dogs or
whatever right well what's it happen the
Chinese are a bit freaked out you know
our guy on the inside is is now gone so
I think there are some other channels
besides just us invading that
we could press on okay well once again
people say that and then they don't have
any will there ever be a gay president
or even another unmarried one who was
the last unmarried one was it canon I
think you can it wasn't it one of them
was a bachelor in the 2011 Coolidge
Calvin Coolidge Calvin Coolidge but I
didn't go to the University of why is
that a point of Honor what do you think
a gay or Bachelor president I think day
before bachelor someday I'm gonna be a
while I think we're gonna have a woman
first we are definitely gonna have a
woman first although I mean I was very
surprised to see this week that Joe
Biden is on the not so fast train he's
like you know what don't count out old
Uncle Joe I think the reason I think
he's doing that is because I think he
wants to be VP well he again but I think
what he knows is that Hillary has a lot
of baggage some bad [ __ ] could happen
and then he will be takes place to pick
up the pieces I want to be around to
pick up the pieces
okay the only runner up they have I mean
he's really the only second the only guy
who got me guys are actually gonna be
plenty of other people and I think it
actually I'm not rooting for Democrats
but if I were a Democrat I'd be a little
worried about the coronation of Hillary
I prefer to have a competitive race
right Elizabeth Warren I would prefer to
have
a party person should be agreed with
your last rant about all the rich and
really Tea Party the Tea Party hate
those people that's what the Tea Party
will rebellion well with the hit but
they vote with them so stand there crony
capitalism the big government is also a
big problem but they are not happy on
look party you've got a major East
German judge at the Olympics thing going
where you know president hits a flip and
does whatever they give them a to you
know they got as the Koch brother it
doesn't actually matter but they vote
with them they vote for who you
alternative liberal look at the liberal
alternative Obama's crony capitalist and
bailing out Wall Street as you said no
one on Wall Street in the log and the
show defending the bailouts and you
entered the show hacking but you did the
thing again building the originals your
sense of logic is amazing to me I like
to amaze you we needed the bailouts
because be your boyfriend George Bush
a flaming pile of dog [ __ ] on the White
House steps where we were losing 750,000
I'd agree with that part but but that
look the the the thing is the conflating
of the bailouts that it was Obama who
did that when virtually all the bank's
took place before he got there all I'm
saying is establishments of both parties
I know you know job creators are
fantastic and as long as you get out of
their way and stop regulating and every
once in a while give them a hundred
billion dollars everything works great
in the American economy doesn't it I
think the one thing you forget is that
in the United States the real job
creators are middle-class consumers
right our economy's seventy percent
based on what people buy it's based on
consuming and when you have a middle
class that is not able to keep the
wealth that earns we're hollowing out
our economy right and it's not working
we're gonna have stagnation continued as
long as people can't keep what they earn
where was he the first hour
[Applause]
I thought it was with you Bruce why
don't Democritus Richard asked the panel
focused more on eliminating tax
loopholes
why don't they Austan Goolsbee
they do they I mean once you're in
Congress through nil effect there yes
that's what I grid they put a focus on
it but to nil effect because you know
whether it's meat whether it's whatever
industry there's a lot a lot of money in
Washington that people are pushing on
the to prevent I was in Denver in 2008
when you gave a briefing during the
Obama convention about how Democrats and
the Obama administration when they got
elected would take on tax reform and
entitlement reform and so you hearing
you talk about this makes me wonder what
happened
well the same thing that happened to me
know look back up and they got the tea
party happened I mean in many of these
discussions we reality happened
well reality and priorities happens and
it's Sunday night it would have been
nice so would meet and GMOs and a lot of
other things environmental stuff that
you know we're gonna stop all I'll say
is it's not it is not the case and if
you if you're meaning to imply look the
president got there and then he took all
those plans that threw him away that's
not true
they proposed in the budget the
president proposes tax reform proposes
various cuts has proposed entitlement
reforms it goes nowhere Dave camp has
tax reform out now any chance okay last
question do you think the Tea Party will
cost Republicans the midterm elections
in 2014 and the presidential election in
2016 well there is some historic
precedents for that question because we
know that they did cloth seats for the
Republicans in 2010 and 2012 tea party
was responsible for in large part the
huge Republican gains in 2010 they cost
him a couple of Senate seats with bad
candidates but all the end they didn't
pick up 64 House seats a lot of
governorships right publicans I think
will win the Senate this year and it's
2016 is the tougher will be a close race
we can make fun of the Tea Party all we
want right but you know what in five
years they are baked into the cake that
they don't want gays to eat
of this country they came pretty darn
far I mean you know I wish Occupy Wall
Street was nearly as influential as the
do part they're not says that same guy
still out in the tents oh my god out
there right it's raining today if I were
to say one thing please do help the
country because I'm kind of ignorant to
all the stuff that's going on the
country needs to continue to dare to
dream I do that well said who the [ __ ]
is gonna argue with Real Time with Bill
Maher ask villainous guests your
questions right after the show
at hbo.com or on Twitter